cd lamb joins a proud tradition of
dallas cowboys who have worn the number
88 it really started with drew pearson
back in the 70s notwithstanding his
push-off against the vikings in the 1975
playoffs drew pearson one of the
all-time great cowboys and then the
legend grew with michael irvin and then
it was passed to antonio bryant and then
dez bryant and now cd lamp now along the
way and this is kind of weird i didn't
know this until yesterday big cat
michael arvin had his career end due to
injury in 1999. the very next year they
issued number 88 to tight end jackie
harris now i know that irvin wasn't the
original 88 but it's just kind of weird
they didn't shelve it for a year or two
after irving retired
yeah that is a little weird i do kind of
like this though the tradition that goes
with this uh certain number it's kind of
like wearing 10 in soccer if you're a
footy fan like myself uh mike trivia
question what's the only number retired
for the dallas cowboys
there are none
there you go you got it trick question
yeah you two i kind of like you're
trying to check i kind of like that they
don't have any numbers retired i you
know retiring numbers
i get it but i i i also think it's kind
of cool when the when even you know
what's cooler than retiring a number is
just retiring it without giving the
retirement so like no one wears it ever
again but it's not officially retired i
kind of like that
i i have always been against the concept
of retiring numbers because
i think long-term like at some point
you're going to run out of numbers to
retire
you can't retire anymore and then you're
going to have a guy who's better than
anyone you've ever had in your franchise
what do you do and then like assuming
that football survives 100 200 300 years
like you've retired numbers for names
that the modern fan has no idea who in
the hell they are i just it's it's like
i i worry from time to time about when
all the landfills are going to fill up
and where are we going to put all the
garbage it's kind of the same idea at
some point you're going to run out of
numbers you can't retire numbers you
have to save the numbers
have you lost sleep over this like
yes i have the boston celtics have
retired way too many numbers yes
yes well it's easier it's easier in
basketball because you only got 12 guys
on the team in football you got 53. so
you have a finite number of of numbers
you can ever retire so yeah i mean look
the cowboys haven't retired number 12
but there's no way in hell anybody's
wearing roger stahlbach's number right
you haven't retired number 22 there's no
way in hell anybody's wearing emmitt
smith's number right so you do it
unofficially just do it that way and
then 100 years from now
frankly who cares about roger staubach
and emmitt smith
you must have uh loved the gesture by
mlb but had a mini anxiety attack when
they retired jackie robinson's number
across the league you probably really
like you have a big you have a big cork
board in your in your barn and you're
like oh my god that's just a number that
we're just crossing off for every single
team we're running out of numbers
no that's okay but you can't do that
very often you can you can get away with
one and i think the circumstance is more
than justified obviously but you can't
you can't be doing that you know every
ten years or yeah eventually you're just
gonna have guys running around uh with a
bunch of jerseys don't have numbers on
them and here's the other thing too
while we're on this why the hell do
baseball players even have numbers you
don't need numbers to be do you need a
number to be a baseball player
yeah because you always well you want to
sell jerseys
i did i know you want to i mean that's
the only reason to do it though there's
no independent significance to having
think about it to having a number for
everybody
yeah what about keeping a box score
that's a fun baseball thing okay
yeah you just use their last name you
could use the position they play of
course then you would be doubled up if
you have two right fielders so there you
go it's confusing you number the
positions and you number the players
it's too many numbers for one person to
process you put me in a box in that one
i'll agree
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports